the 2020 census I've been talking to you
about it for a while in fact just a
couple weeks ago I told you that the
previous guy who was running the 2020
census resigned that funding for the
2020 census has been cut and that we're
really on track for an absolute and
total disaster with the 2020 census and
the census is really important I don't
not gonna redo the entire explanation of
why it's so important but number one at
the top of the list the census directly
impacts redistricting and gerrymandering
but it's also important for lots of
other reasons it determines how funding
for certain programs is distributed and
what groups are actually going to have
really important programs properly
funded and it's a very very long list
and Donald Trump and Republicans seem to
have or if they don't if it's not
deliberate then it's going to have this
effect anyway from but Republicans seem
to have a really clear plan to actually
rig the census in their favor and this
is going to impact a politics for a very
very long time much like selecting
Supreme Court justices being able to
influence a census impacts the political
reality of the United States for a long
period of time and in the case of the
census it's about a decade the news is
that Donald Trump is looking at Thomas
Brunell to run the census okay Thomas
Bernal has no government experience
period which is already weird for
somebody who is directing the census but
what Thomas Bernal does have is
experience in helping Republicans redraw
congressional districts to their
specific advantage what we know of as
gerrymandering and in fact Brunel wrote
a book specifically about redistricting
in a way that will make elections less
competitive and better for Republicans
the book has the not at all subtle title
of redistricting and representation why
competitive elections are bad for
America you can't really get clearer
about your goal than the title of his
book right and you might hear me say
this and say well David Democrats pick
partisan lefties to run the census and
Republicans get to pick partisan
righties to run the census it's because
Alec
have consequences and you would be
completely wrong the typical census
director is someone who has worked for
the government for a while and
importantly typically has a background
in mathematics or statistics period that
is not what Thomas Brunel is and the
Republicans and Trump are so clearly
planning to rig the census and the
census is again I think the best analogy
is like selecting a Supreme Court
justice you can have a lasting impact on
the country well beyond your own
presidency if you pick Supreme Court
justices and if you determine the way
that the census is going to be done when
you have an inaccurate census you can
make immigrants suffer you can make
minorities suffer it can make elections
disproportionately unfairly difficult to
win for Democrats and easier for
Republicans this is a power grab at the
highest level do not be confused now
what can Democrats do well they can't
block the selection since they're not
subject to Senate confirmation the
census director is not subject to Senate
confirmation what Democrats maybe could
do and it really depends on you is they
can get themselves elected in 2018
because if Democrats can control the
House and Senate Congress controls the
budget for the census is that even a
victory if Thomas Brunell is running it
maybe not right because yeah if you
control the money you can I guess try to
make money available for what it's
actually supposed to be available for in
the census and prevent money from going
into the rigging but the truth is that
even if Democrats take control of the
House and Senate in 2018 if Trump elects
this guy it's going to be very difficult
to prevent him from doing whatever the
hell he wants the other problem is that
so much of this is done on the state
level too right yeah right and Democrats
have minorities all over the country and
legislators is it
it's the census is basically like 50
censuses or sent sense I I don't know
what the plural is because each state is
kind of running their census as directed
by the Census Bureau I believe if I may
take that information and decide how to
divide up the districts yeah
correct
yeah that's that's a real problem
because isn't it but do we have 34 or so
governorships that are controlled by
Republicans and nevermind the number of
state legislative state legislatures etc
it's depressing I wish I had some silver
lining and sometimes Pat comes up with
these relatively bogus but at least they
inspire a little bit of lightheartedness
silver linings we've got net neutrality
which by all accounts is going to be
repealed we had an interview with Andrew
Torres attorney about this earlier this
week and he's saying like yeah it's it's
probably just going to be repeal that I
don't know of any way that we're really
going to stop that the census
increasingly appears that it is going to
be rigged or at minimum screwed up
period we can vote I think that's the
only silver lining which is that if we
commit ourselves to having higher
turnout than the right for the next 15
years we can slowly undo and retake
control of all of these disasters that
Republicans are committed yeah I mean
forgive my pessimism I just don't know
if there's enough time to because I
think it takes quite a few election
cycles they turn this all around
absolutely and we only have two years
until 2020 we really we really only have
a couple years until 2020 I mean it's
insane that the midterms are 11 months
away the midterms are 11 months away and
I'm just not seeing the motivation
enthusiasm and most importantly like the
urgency from the left and I know it's a
it's all bad with Trump and we had the
Marches and maybe Doug Jones could win
an Alabama although it's increasingly
looking not good there should be way
more progressives involved already with
with 2018 yeah I mean I'm there's
certainly like this anti-trump sentiment
but I think plenty of Republicans are
able to distance themselves from Donald
Trump and they're not getting the
effects that he has from low approval
numbers yeah the Republicans are going
to be able to strategically distance
from Trump when it makes sense or
aligned with Trump when it makes sense
depending on how Trump is doing in their
district and their state whatever and I
I hope I'm wrong and I hope that over
the next couple months particularly you
listen if by March 1st there is not very
clear and
significant enthusiasm and engagement
from the left on the midterms its it's
gonna be a losing battle I don't know
how else to say it so if I'm just
missing the enthusiasm and if you can
not oh I'm really enthusiastic David but
if there's actual data you can send me
which points to significant left-wing
enthusiasm for 2018 let me know I want
to see it I hope I'm wrong
perhaps the Alabama Senate race will be
a bellwether for this maybe although I'm
increasingly skeptical about that send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by wink at try wink comm slash
Pakman I am terrible at choosing wine
tasting wine figuring out what the
flavor notes are I couldn't possibly
describe to you what wines I like and
what wines I dislike and one of the
great things that the wink system does
is give you a sort of palette
questionnaire where you are asked
questions about how you like your coffee
if you like coffee what fruits do you
prefer and from your answers the wink
system will develop personalized wine
recommendations for you and you can get
$20 off by going to try wink comm slash
Pakman that's t ry wi and c.com slash
Pakman the wines get delivered to your
door you get to try different rare and
interesting wines from different parts
of the world and most importantly they
are tailored to your tastes and as you
rate wines on the wink website the
recommendations further improve for you
and you end up with really great
personalized wines that you will like
you can pay no membership fee you can
skip any month you can cancel anytime
and wink has a 100% satisfaction
guarantee
so you don't end up paying for bottles
of wine that you don't like and maybe
most importantly most excitingly for a
limited time you can save $20 when you
try wink at try wink comm slash Pakman
that is tr y winc comm /p a que ma n try
it save 20 bucks